[Music]
there's a sleeping service dog in here
where
let me see
can you get a camera back there
is that true
look good i'm just sitting there isn't
that sweet with all that with all that
clapping and standing he stayed right
there you know what
it's clear he's seen this show before
yeah
he is not a fan
that dog when he thought he was that
ellen was like oh here we go
and then conan
that's all right i was tired anyway
[Laughter]
what better commentary on our show
tonight we've got a great one for you
tonight
[Laughter]
it'll put your dog right to sleep
tonight's show no we have a great show
this evening and i'm going to start with
a big announcement i don't know if
you're aware but today is international
women's day isn't that nice
yes
and uh in honor of this occasion ladies
tonight's first guest is jon hamm
he's taking you all out to a movie huh
[Applause]
i should have asked him about that first
the notebook yeah
ah what's going on right now hey uh
shocking new information just came out
about the death of osama bin laden did
you hear this news today this is
interesting it was reported that in the
weeks leading up to his death osama bin
laden had trouble controlling the
squabbling among his three wives
that's true yeah in fact when seal team
sixth knocked down the door bin laden
said thank god you're here
two in the chest one in the head let's
do this
we've all been there in moments
please steal team six
just kidding honey
love you baby
she doesn't watch the show uh
my my wife is as interested in this show
as that sleeping dog right now
does your wife have a tag that says do
not pet yeah
[Applause]
nice
wow
that was a really funny ad-lib dog
wouldn't give it up for that
i walk this dog here every night yeah
it's keeping us very humble
what else is going on uh they just uh
unjailed they just they just unveiled
the new ipad that's a lot of people are
talking about that
according to apple the new ipad isn't
called the ipad 3 or the ipad hd in fact
it doesn't have a name yet yeah right
now everyone's using its nickname the i
can't believe i just paid full price for
the ipad 2.
were there people that bought that like
three days ago i know bought the ipad 2
three days ago and then they're like
there's a new one that's much better for
the same price right suckers
and they sold it to them too just like
sure yeah it's great take it
yeah i hear there's a new one coming out
not for a while here you go
wow
your apple store is creepy yeah
oh
all that face walking to the apple store
why am i making that the guy i have no
idea well no free apple stuff for this
guy
now uh what else is going on good news
for president obama the latest polls
show president obama's approval ratings
among women have risen by 10 percent
yeah he's up by 10
yeah many people believe this uh
increase is due to obama's new campaign
slogan tell me about your day
[Applause]
yeah
in a few months he's going to unveil his
next one would you like some white wine
and a foot massage
actually that would work on me too yeah
yeah
okay yeah